bonjour le biarrot ce genre on m'a vu
resurgir ce week-end avec une forme de
cruauté la haine anti-flic l'appel à se
suicider lancé samedi aux forces de
l'ordre par des manifestants a suscité
beaucoup d'indignation c'était à paris
les mêmes propos ont été écrits sur les
murs d'une gendarmerie en bretagne
est-ce que la réponse à ce phénomène
peut être seulement pénale la réponse à
ce phénomène doit être pénalement avec
une chaîne pénale qui suivait qu'ils
fassent preuve d'autorité du début à la
fin
parce que face à ces personnes qui ont
été biberonné à la haine des
institutions à la haine des policiers à
la haine de l'état l'autorité la fermeté
doit être absolue et je voudrais redire
à tous mon soutien aux forces de l'ordre
qui se dévouent week-end après week-end
et depuis des années pour notre sécurité
pour pour nous protéger et on ne peut
pas dire je suis flic après le bataclan
après à charlie hebdo les embrasser et
ensuite appelé et se réjouir du suicide
chez les forces de l'ordre je voudrais
dire un mot à la famille de 7,7
policière cette mère de famille qui
s'est suicidé a récemment et qui laisse
deux orphelins emmanuel macron peut-il
mettre fin à la crise sociale avec ce
qu'il va annoncer jeudi soir il doit
mettre fin à cette crise sociale il va
trouver les mots il doit apporter à les
réponses mais je doute qu'ils sont en
capacité de le faire car rappelons que
la crise des gilets jaunes et au ciné de
7,2 de ce mépris de cette violence
verbale de la part du président de la
république qui a parlé de gaulois
réfractaires qui a eu de nombreux maux
propos qui ont blessé les français qui
les ont humilié et cela a réveillé cette
cette colère pour le moment il n'a pas
su apporter les réponses nous ce que
nous proposons aux républicains c'est
une baisse des des impôts pour tous
surtout les classes moyennes sont ceux
qui souffrent le plus du matraquage
fiscal 10% de baisse d'impôts pour à
tous et puis quand même il ya deux tiers
des retraités qui ont perdu du pouvoir
d'achat ce qui est assez inédit depuis
1945 et il faut remettre sur l'inflation
les pensions de retraite pour tous les
retraités les ré indexé sur l'inflation
annulé les hausses de cg pour tous les
retraités et pas seulement pour ceux qui
ont deux mille euros de retraite à deux
puisque les républicains pourraient
soutenir puisque c'est une idée dont on
n'entend calais dans l'air l'idée d'une
journée de travail non rémunéré ou la
suppression d'un nouveau jour de congé
pour financer la dépendance
je pense que c'est ce n'est pas la
solution je pense que ça serait une
mauvaise solution ça serait une forme
d'impôt déguisée c'est une solution très
vieux monde aussi à mon sens je pense
pouvoir baisser massivement les impôts
il faut quand même pouvoir revoir la
dépense publique ça sera la mère de
toutes les réformes mais on en fait
énormément de propositions pour faire
baisser cette dépense publique
il faudrait que le président puisse les
entendre mais pour financer la
dépendance ce n'est pas une baisse
d'impôt déguisée avec une nouvelle
journée de solidarité qui pourra
apporter la solution je pense que c'est
une mauvaise piste on va évoquer les
européennes était gay ou savait que
cette information d'abord révélée par
nos confrères de médiapart
hier matin les oiseaux la tête de liste
de la république en marche a été
candidate à des élections étudiantes aux
côtés de militants d'extrême droite
quand elle était à sciences po c'était
en 1984 qu'est-ce que vous inspire cette
révélation
mais c'est encore les donneurs de leçons
anachronisme qui sont les héritiers de
cette gauche bien pensante
c'est quand même la gauche la république
en marche qui donne des leçons à tout le
monde qu'ils sont dans cette pensée
molle et qui ont finalement commencé à
l'extrême droite
moi je voudrais quand même revenir sur
la défense de nathalie l'oiseau quand
même aller tenterait peine après pena à
sciences po paris donc en 4e année à
sciences po paris et elle ne sait pas
quelle est la couleur politique de ce
syndicat étudiant j'ai l'impression
qu'elle se moque un petit peu du monde
quand on est en pré pena on sait quels
sont les mouvements politiques on
connaît l'histoire politique de la
france et on ne s'engage pas à la légère
dans un mouvement d'extrême droite je
trouve que ça la disqualifie elle qui se
présente souvent comme le rempart face à
l'extrême droite
c'est un retour de bâton et ça démontre
un peu l'hypocrisie de certains membres
du gouvernement
et puis cette liste aux européennes
puisqu'on parle d europe l la république
en marche qui n'a pas de programme qui
va présenter son programme deux semaines
avant le scrutin je crois le 9 mai ça
laisse très peu de temps pour le débat
qui a une liste totalement incohérente
avec un agriculteur et en même temps
monsieur qu'enfant qui est un écologisme
monsieur canfin qui renoue ses bâtiments
quand même ça ça incompatibles quand on
connaît les positions des uns et des
autres monsieur canfin qui refusent qui
a refusé de monter dans un avion qui
expulsé à un migrant qui avait été
condamné suite à un viol sur mineure
donc c'est une liste qui n'a aucune
cohérence qui n'a pas de programme qu'on
nous présente aujourd'hui et à laquelle
on a mis nathalie oiseaux à la tête qui
représente vraiment toute la
technocratie très froides que les
français rejettent alors chez vous chez
les républicains de nombreux cadres se
réjouir devant les intentions de vote
aux européennes remonter aujourd'hui
c'est au tour de 14%
fin décembre c'était à peu près 8 %
certains y voient un effet bel ami
françois-xavier bellamy votre tête de
liste mais 14% pour les républicains
finalement ça n'est quand même pas grand
chose est ce que on n'est pas chez vous
en train de se préparer tout doucement à
l'idée de se contenter de peu
non absolument pas et comme vous le
rappeler on était à 8 % il ya quelques
mois on a quasiment doublé à ce score je
pense qu'on va encore progresser parce
qu'on est la seule famille politique
avoir un programme concret pragmatique
au service de la france au service des
français pour refonder l'europe
on a une équipe qui est déterminé qui
est cohérente c'est les françois-xavier
belhani fait un travail formidable
l'ensemble de l'équipe se déploie sur
tout territoire moi même look un
prochain je serai en dordogne j'étais
dans le val d'oise et je vais me
déplacer à nier c'est vrai arnaud
danjean il ya des personnalités très
solide sur cette liste il ya quelques
années encore failli à deux ans on
disait que la droite républicaine était
morte et c'est absolument triste
de d'imaginer la france sans une droite
républicaine et c'est vraiment le
fantasme emmanuel macron et de la
république en marche de vouloir mettre
comme unique opposant l'extrême droite
non la droite républicaine et bien
debout elle double son score
elle travaille elle avance elle se
reconstruit et je pense qu'on va
démultiplier nos efforts pour avoir une
dynamique encore plus importante et crée
la surprise et faire mentir les sondages
je pense qu'on a encore en
reconstruction mais que les fondations
sont solides et qu'on aura une belle
surprise le soir du scrutin
essama une première étape avant ali
municipal et les autres ges et sciences
le seconde campagne des républicains
pourraient être dévoilées ce soir lors
d'un meeting à caen a priori ce sera
refonder l'europe rétablir la france qui
n'a pas proposé de refonder de
transformer de réformes et l'europe
depuis au moins 40 ans est ce que est ce
que ce genre de formules n'est pas
totalement discréditée je vous remercie
pour cette question parce que parce
qu'elle va droit au but et c'est vrai
que il ya des formules des slogans qui
ont lassé les français surtout des
promesses qui n'ont pas été tenues qui
on a éloigné les français de la
politique c'est pas sûr d'en c'est un
programme sans programme d'action on
fera une europe toute façon l'europe
connaît une crise comme elle n'a jamais
connu
c'est soit elle se réforme soit elle se
refonde soit elle disparaît et pour
pouvoir se réformer pour pouvoir se
refonder faut qu'elle s'appuie sur des
nations fortes et donc nous ce que nous
proposons c'est une france forte dans
une europe qui va au service des
français et des nations et ce soir nous
nous réunissons attendant pas pu tenir
le meeting de nine qui était liting de
lancement puisque il ya eu cet événement
dramatique de notre dame
mais ce soir à quand la droite est
rassemblée avec les centristes ça sera
en présence évidemment de laurent
wauquiez françois-xavier bellamy des
membres de la liste mais également
gérard larcher et hervé morin donc c'est
la preuve qu'on est con et rassembler et
déterminé pour pour cette échéance et je
suis très heureuse d'ailleurs c'est
aussi l'effet bellamy puisque gérard
larcher initialement était avec quelques
réserves et aujourd'hui il est déterminé
à faire campagne pour que les
républicains soient au plus haut
le sort du premier tour pour ces
élections merci didier rous mars est la
journée